did you city lower Bruce my father is a
lawyer did you I did not write long what
is fascinating right is that no new
legal scholar could do a better job of
explaining the legal intricacies that
Bruce Cohen just did and one of the
things that fascinates us is the passion
that you bring to an area that you care
about even though your expertise has
been in filmmaking but but you hear that
passion and that content that obviously
took a lot of time in developing that
expertise that allows you to fulfill all
these other areas of your life but I
want to turn to let me just sure say
because this goes back to part of your
question right we hadn't really gotten
to yet which was the you know connection
between my career and whatever success
I've have achieved in the career and the
philanthropic work and they what I have
found is that they there's a beautiful
karmic flow back and forth where
everything that I'm doing and
experiencing and learning from in the
philanthropic world and in the political
world really helps and informs my
filmmaking and vice versa and what you
just described was that's a fundamental
part of producing a movie every every
movie you start you are not an expert on
whatever the subject is about most
likely you even if you might have so
passing interest but you don't know the
setting you don't know the characters
you don't know the jobs they're doing
you don't know the situation they're
doing but your job overseeing a crew is
you are now going to become an expert on
the world of whatever that movie is when
you're doing hook you need to learn
everything there was about pirate ships
and Peter Pan and fictional stuff when
you're doing alive which was the
Uruguayan rugby team crashing in Andy's
we learned everything there was to know
about survival in the wilderness for 62
days with Harvey Milk you know you
become an expert on Harvey's life you
you you you end up what having more
access and more information on Harvey
and his friends then perhaps anyone
who's come before you just by that
definition that you're the first people
doing a narrative
film about him where you're needing to
learn all this information so the
needing to become an expert in a field
that you previously were not an expert
in and then translating that to the
public in a way that they will
understand and be moved by and be
entertained by that's your job as a
producer so there's no more perfect job
than that suited to the world of
philanthropy and politics